- [Instructor] When we talk about the big
social movements of the early
19th century in the United States,
you can't deny that the emergence
of Jacksonian democracy is one of the most
influential aspects of
early 19th century culture,
so what was Jacksonian democracy
and why do we care so much about it?
Well, I wanna make the
argument to you that
Jacksonian democracy was really the birth
of modern American political culture.
By that, I mean that during this time,
lots of practices emerged
that are still with us today.
For example, the two party system.
The spoils system.
Even some aspects of
American political character
that are still with us today
emerged in this time period
and by that, I mean the kinds of traits
that we like to see in our politicians
to consider them electable.
So in this series on Jacksonian democracy,
I'm gonna take you on a journey from
the earlier American political culture,
some of the major changes that
came about in the Jacksonian period,
and then just discuss some of the ways
that this still influences us today.
All right, so if Jacksonian democracy
was a new thing, what came before it?
Well, in the very early era
of American political life
and I'm talking here from
approximately 1790 to about 1820,
American politics was very aristocratic.
There were a couple of families
that tended to dominate politics.
The Adams family, for example.
George Washington, Thomas Jefferson,
and these men were kind
of considered to be,
maybe a higher character of man.
They were the quintessential
citizens of a republic
and along with that came a certain amount
of wealth and status and education.
In between George Washington
and Andrew Jackson,
every single person
who served as president
had a college degree.
Many of them were Virginians
and particularly Virginian planters.
You see a lot of Virginians
and a lot of people from Massachusetts
in the first couple of
years of the republic.
Many of them kind of shared a concern
that there could be too much
democracy, shall we say,
that even though the United
States was a democracy,
many of the founders of the United States
worried about the tyranny of the majority,
the tyranny of the mob,
that they had set up this
democratic experiment
where many people could vote,
but they were afraid of having
just too many people voting
'cause they looked down on lower classes
of society in that time period.
They worried that if you didn't
have a stake in the country,
usually shown by property ownership,
either in terms of land
or in terms of wealth,
then you wouldn't have
the proper investment
in the fate of the nation in order to
make a rational decision about what
sort of policies should be enacted.
So in the early years
of the United States,
many states had voting laws
that restricted the franchise
to just propertied men.
So really, a quite small
proportion of the overall populous
of the United States could vote.
Interestingly, this actually meant that
in some northern states,
both free people of color,
free black men
and women could vote
because they met the requirements
for property ownership,
but in the early 1800s, 1810s,
these ideals of democracy
began to catch on more and more
among the common people
and as new states joined The
Union, like Ohio and Illinois,
they came in with state constitutions,
saying that all white
male citizens could vote,
regardless of whether or not
they owned property or they paid taxes.
So in this time period,
white male citizenship
became associated with voting
and some of the other
states began to rewrite
their state constitutions
to grant the vote
to all white males and it
probably won't surprise you
that when they rewrote those laws,
they managed to take
out the little loophole
for free people of color and women
with certain amounts of property.
So by the end of this
period, in the 1850s,
all property requirements for
voting had been eliminated
and any white male above the age of 21
in the United States had the right to vote
and we'll get to what that meant
for American politics in the next video.